Hola Bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de France 24 sobre el Éxodo los
saluda Julieth riaño
[Música]
entre las varias polémicas que rodean al
Mundial de fútbol de Qatar está la de
los miles de trabajadores migrantes y
sus familias que exigen compensación
verdad y Justicia un evento deportivo en
el que precisamente los migrantes
también son protagonistas dentro de las
canchas en este programa veremos Cómo la
fuerza migrante está presente en Qatar
2022 desde dos perspectivas por un lado
por los migrantes que trabajaron
arduamente para que el evento fuera
posible y por otro por ser un mundial
que marca un hito en el número de
jugadores que participan sin representar
a su país de nacimiento esto último lo
explicamos a continuación una
celebración silenciosa que llamó la
atención del mundo brelen bolo es un
camerunés que en el mundial de Qatar
viste la camiseta de Suiza en este
partido enfrentó a su país de nacimiento
y anotó el único gol que le dio la
victoria a su equipo de allí la razón de
su reservado festejo desde el sorteo he
recibido esta pregunta unas 10.000 veces
por eso me río un poco pero es muy
especial país natal mi mamá y mi papá
vienen de allí entonces es un juego
especial para mí y para mi familia
algo que entendió la afición cameronesa
jugamos un excelente futuro en el primer
tiempo pero en el segundo tiempo no fue
así nos relajamos y por eso en bolo tuvo
la oportunidad de marcar
[Música]
lampa no lo culpamos es nuestro
compatriota él solo jugó para su
federación y lo felicitamos
el caso en bolo llamó la atención sobre
la fuerza migrante dentro de los equipos
que participan en el mundial de Qatar
uno especialmente criticado por los
abusos hacia trabajadores migrantes
en las canchas 137 futbolistas visten
una camiseta diferente a la del país en
el que nacieron es decir al menos el 16%
del total de jugadores presentes en el
Torneo explicado de otra manera uno de
cada seis deportistas son migrantes
Marruecos es muestra de ello su
selección es la única con más de la
mitad de sus 26 jugadores nacidos en
otro país senegal túnez y Qatar son
también algunos de los ejemplos ahora
veamos lo que pasa con las selecciones
africanas en Qatar el 42% de los 130
jugadores de sus equipos nacieron fuera
del continente en su mayoría en Francia
de los 59 jugadores nacidos en Francia
participantes en el mundial más de la
mitad representan a equipos africanos
otro de los casos más sonados es el de
iñaki Williams un jugador de 28 años
nacido en España y de padres ganeses que
fue convocado por ghana mientras su
hermano juega con la roja
los espectaculares escenarios deportivos
de Qatar 2022 fueron levantados bajo el
sol abrasador del emirato y son muy
cuestionadas las garantías laborales que
se brindaron a los trabajadores
migrantes muchos de ellos aunque no se
sabe con Claridad Cuántos murieron al
construir los estadios que hoy albergan
la copa del mundo
vestidos con la camiseta de una
selección que no es la suya estos
trabajadores migrantes disfrutan ahora
del mundial de Qatar más de 15.000 de
ellos se reúnen en esta fan Zone en doha
para ver de lejos algunos de los
escenarios que ellos mismos ayudaron a
construir
albi paleno
todo se divierten aquí pero yo no tengo
oportunidad no hay posibilidad de ir al
estadio solo vengo aquí y disfruto desde
el exterior
pero no todos los que participaron de
las mega construcciones que hicieron
posible el mundial pudieron ver el
pitazo inicial la organización catari
reconoció la muerte de entre 400 y 500
obreros migrantes Durante los
preparativos del torneo un dato mucho
menor al denunciado por organizaciones
de Derechos Humanos durante años cientos
de trabajadores de diferentes países de
Asia y África viajaron a Qatar para
trabajar en los proyectos de
construcción del mundial atraídos por
los pagos y la oportunidad laboral pero
Qatar no les cumplió los bajos salarios
e incluso el impago fueron parte de lo
que vivieron algunos quedaron con
lesiones de por vida babu cayó cuatro
metros mientras trabajaba en una de las
construcciones estuvo cuatro meses en
coma y perdió la visión
cuando recuperé el conocimiento no podía
ver nada le pregunté a mi hermano si el
lugar estaba oscuro me dijo que estaba
bien iluminado no podía creer que había
perdido la vista se lo dije a los
médicos pero ellos no me creyeron
nunca recibió una compensación de su
empleador Mientras que otras familias no
volvieron a ver a sus seres queridos en
esta casa medio construir vive binoda su
esposo fue a trabajar a Qatar pero nunca
regresó
[Música]
cuando estaba vivo enviaba dinero empecé
a construir esta casa y acabamos de
elegir los Pilares cuando murió tomé un
préstamo pero ahora el interés es mucho
más alto no puedo pagar esto
para ella y sus hijos queda solo el
recuerdo de su esposo y padre fue tal la
migración de trabajadores hacia Qatar
que representan más del 80% de los
habitantes del emirato a Kilómetros sus
familiares siguen esperando su regreso o
una respuesta sobre lo que pasó con
ellos
la fuerza laboral de los migrantes dio
vida al Mundial de fútbol de Qatar y en
las canchas muchos jugadores migrantes
también han sido y son protagonistas
hasta que inmigrantes de France 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrante f-24
sigan con más información en francés
24.com
[Música]